Why do you recommend that I take certain supplements 30 minutes away from food?
Because it's typically I recommend you take a binder 30 minutes away from food or a homeopath.
So homeopaths are basically frequencies of items. So you might take a homeopath of mercury.
I want to take mercury holy up it. Well, guarantee if you bring it to an organic chemistry lab,
there's no mercury in that. It's the frequency of mercury and by taking that away from food,
you're not allowing food to interrupt that. And you're taking that to stimulate your body to
enact with mercury in the case of mercury holy path that's helping pull mercury out of your body
and such. As far as a binder goes, you want a binder to bind garbage that your liver has
dumped into the colon. You don't want your binder to bind the minerals that you just ate.
So the idea of taking things away from food is that it won't affect the affected by something
that you just ate.